[Musik]
vernünftig oder zuckersüß eine von
tausend kleinen entscheidungen die wir
alle täglich treffen
warum entscheiden wir wie und lassen wir
uns auch ohne verbote irgendwie lenken
vielleicht durch einen kleinen stups
richtung vernunft katrin löhr ist
sozialwissenschaftlerin
sie erforscht was die entscheidungen von
menschen beeinflusst unser treffpunkt
die mensa der uni osnabrück hier ist
nichts zu fall
die salatbar dominiert den raum denn die
studenten sollen sich gesünder ernähren
das ist die idee dabei das verlag sehr
ansprechend dargestellt und natürlich
habe ich auch alle anderen optionen die
sind praktisch ist im moment in meinem
rücken also der fokus soll auf salat
also das wäre jetzt auch vielleicht in
der schulmensa wäre das eine route die
gutes engagement
natürlich können die studenten trotzdem
noch fritten essen und einiges ungesunde
mehr aber der appetit auf salat ist
größer geworden denn der aufbau der
mensa und die anordnung des essens lenkt
die entscheidungen der studenten na jin
heißt diese technik also nachziehen
heißt erstmal stutzen und hinter diesem
begriff die sind eingriffe sammeln sich
eine ganze zahl von
verschiedenen techniken die sich auf
eine sogenannte entscheidungs
architektur beziehen das ist hört sich
kompliziert an als es ist also das ist
im grunde die welt in der wir leben und
wie sie gebaut ist wie sie gestaltet ist
und diesen techniken die führen dazu
dass man sich in einer bestimmten weise
möglicherweise verhält oder eben nicht
verhält zweites beispiel najin techniken
um ressourcen zu schonen
wie viel papier jemand verbraucht hängt
ganz entscheidend von diesem kleinen
haken ab beidseitig druck und ob
zumindest meistens beidseitig gedruckt
wird oder nicht das hängt von den berg
einstellungen ab mit dem der drucker
geliefert wird das ist praktisch der bau
einer entscheidungs architektur der
darauf abzielt dass die menschen sich in
einer bestimmten weise verhalten
das ist typischerweise so dass menschen
dem folgen was ihnen praktisch angeboten
wird oder wie es voreingestellt ist auch
gerade bei so ganz vielen ritualisierten
ding ist die voreinstellung das
entscheidende dafür wie sich menschen
verhalten ja ein guter grund übrigens
auch mal in die voreinstellung zum
datenschutz zu gucken bisher werden die
standards dort von google und co gesetzt
konzern also die interesse haben an
möglichst vielen daten auch das ist eine
technik disclosure also offenlegung wie
die anderen sich verhalten denn die
meisten menschen wollen sich vergleichen
und dazu gehören
konkret heißt das wer mitte
stromrechnung auch die
durchschnittswerte seiner region und
damit seiner nachbarn erfährt ist eher
geneigt energie zu sparen
viele menschen bei denen funktioniert
dass sie möchten jetzt in der gruppe
dazu gehören das sehen wir in anderen
bereichen der sozialen medien auch sehr
stark und auf dieses auf diesen
mechanismus setzt man dabei der nacht
versucht entscheidungen von menschen zu
beeinflussen
genau wie führen dass mit marketing und
werbung tun
das funktioniert aber auch bei dieser
freizeit sport gruppe hartes training
zweimal die woche
und fast immer sind alle dabei wie geht
das sie haben im voraus bezahlt und das
ist nicht ihre einzige motivation das
ist eine mischung von drei matches im
grunde ist es einmal die selbstbindung
ganz am anfang sich für einen
überschaubaren zeitraum zu binden
in diesem fall sind dass sie ja neun
wochen das ist der erste match dann gibt
es so genannte reminder also
erinnerungen die persönlich kommen dass
man zum training geht wenn man es
vielleicht vergessen hat oder nicht noch
nicht in der stimmung war das dritte ist
auch eine form von social games also das
eingebundensein in seinem sozialen
kontext und diese drei matches zusammen
funktionieren hier
dutchess der kleine stufe richtung gute
vorsätze klappt oft aber nicht immer und
nicht bei jedem
[Musik]